[Music]
in unfit army news yeah that's the one I
want to be on submitted by your midnight
snack
that's sexual right nature isn't in
nature your midnight snack is sexual in
nature is it mind always like lasagna
and pizza and like bad things for you
it's like hey mommy mommy nice name oh
yeah they call people's snacks now am i
caller that person is a snack they do
yeah I've been hung up my [ __ ] whole
big-ass meal I'm a three-course meal I
know what you thought about snack
goddamn party healthy Husky nothing that
starts with an H is really why do I do
it why do I do it
[Music]
a happy lunch yeah thank you
the Chinese army has reported that young
recruits are too fat and masturbate too
much to pass fitness tests this is true
wait what's weird how do you masturbate
too much like they're just too tired cuz
they're like [ __ ] jacked off they
don't want to run today this was a
problem for Chinese people in China it's
a growing problem now because their
middle class is bigger so now they're
eating more like hamburger they're
eating more and they're they're moving
into cities like you know how we had the
Industrial Revolution like a hundred
years ago or whatever that's that's them
that's happening now so they're all
moving into cities they're not living in
the countryside growing them anymore
yeah they're not as active anymore
they're playing video games so they're
becoming Americans pretty much saw this
[ __ ] when they were showing those they
were showing the way a little line or
pie chart or whatever the [ __ ] is
how the influence of American food or
like American dietary what we think the
healthy diet is started going over into
Asia and then their rate of like heart
disease it like that yeah oh yeah soon
as I saw a KFC yeah of course I think
all the younger people are they they
want more like flavors you know like the
Western flavors and different was like
an introduction of like high animal
protein because I'm a majority of Asian
food doesn't have high animal protein
it's like vegetables soup rice and then
like there's a few meat yeah but that's
like a rare thing million one in a small
little area yeah and they don't do it
all day this is that one festival and
they eat you know puppies that's true
cuz we when we were in Japan it was we
got I started getting like protein
cravings look like there's not enough
protein I was like [ __ ] man I'm just
eating noodles all day
yeah it's red meat like I start craving
red meat so much yeah
it has been reported that around 57% of
Quebec hopefuls in the in China are
being rejected for being unhealthy 50
said that's more than half so on it's an
alley to jerk off thank you lazy maybe
they're like jacking off right before
their fitness test and are like [ __ ]
well they're saying that they're a
percent of the men who applied they had
unusually large testicular veins
reportedly due to excessive masturbation
I was excessively large they just just
sit around jack up all day
there was no like gold yeah you know
that you could possibly achieve to get
out of the rat race well and so
apparently a lot of the applicants have
poor eyesight which also makes their
watching forward all days they need that
you more beta-carotene I'm sorry but you
better believe in every Ken Burns
documentary there's a couple missing
photos of soldiers jerkin it in the
trenches because they did that [ __ ] you
bet your ass in every [ __ ] war world
war ii vomited reliable war oh yeah
they're all spanking yeah I mean man in
general in life is gonna beat it at
least several times a week right I mean
I'm gonna get what that has to do those
things craze is a week is like not in
both of my hands were broken what do
they do they say like the problem of
jacking off is causing something or
anything like that like I get the
obesity things or like unfit but then
they're just adding in their shame them
it's like lazier that's what they're
saying I think that's true I had a
teenage kid and he was walking around
pouty and upset and my you didn't jack
off i'ma let you lock your door for the
week have a de to come out a nice person
you little [ __ ] yeah Jesus how many
times do you think those the guys who
swear themselves away for life what the
[ __ ] is a quick Collard the Collard men
pretty streets dude those guys space
crazy dude you turn on a black light in
the Church of getting nuts in there
Oh God I bet you anything I mean it to
think monks not supposed to though right
no right but that something they're not
supposed to jackoff
they're still human how do you separate
your brain from that [ __ ] they have
white dreams and they have to like it
was such an interesting thing because
like obviously like you know these
articles came out about a lot of priests
who are having sex with young children
so I'm trying to figure out the logic in
that it's like it's immoral to have sex
with a woman but a little boy okay yeah
maybe that's how they were able to go
and Dupree so like well I don't want to
have sex not in any way and they're
attracted to little kids not really cuz
apparently we [ __ ] the nuns a lot too
oh all right
depending like secret abortions I was
just need to be this drill sergeant
who's like you know he's got to say
something completely hypocritical like
he's sweating he's like hey I think you
guys jerk too much it was like he does
the same [ __ ] yeah I mean they get
rejected on application I wouldn't mind
getting rejected was rejecting of Jim
jerks are too much - yeah so they're uh
they've posted some recommendations for
potential candidates to follow so
there's ten of them here's number one
don't be fat it says cut out fizzy
drinks and alcohol to spend less time in
front of screams number three exercise
more number four cut down on computer
games and or masturbating don't do the
same time stop doing the same time both
of them you're gonna get a headache
stomachache sighs that's it let's
continue this list because I already do
all these so let's continue number five
develop better sleeping habit don't have
that number six don't get a tattoo oh I
don't have a military guys are freaking
number seven drink clean water dirty
water
number eight seek corrective treatment
for genetic conditions such as excessive
sweating or flat feet how do you say
classy
ethic shoes I don't think I have
excessive sweating excessive sweating
because of a genetic reason that he's
been fat yeah I think that's the reason
yeah yeah whatever 9 yeah who won't be
there so much number 9 seek treatment
for mental health issues I have plenty
of those
number 10 have better standards of
hygiene and sanitation
oh I'm extra clean so I got that what a
seek tree treatment for mental health
issues is like this is what I'm doing
I'm joining military yeah or that I want
to blow [ __ ] up all right I think it's a
terrible idea for you to tell soldiers
not to jack off Thank You Alan
masturbation should ever be banned for
anyone no you can't sit tell someone at
work on their mental health and then
take away masturbation yeah like that's
part of mental health I feel like and I
want be happy I don't wanna join the
military you know I mean so people are
getting denied because they're not
passing what test lightness yeah the
just the inspection that just means you
need to [ __ ] work out eat right and
sleep right that's it but they don't
want to this is why porn shouldn't be
for you dude it's [ __ ] everything up
yeah it's [ __ ] it all up now so does
that mean like half of the people that
are signing up are these malnourished
scrawny guys that are like trying to be
soldiers isn't it like a mandatory
overweight yeah it's so I don't think
it's mandatory in China I think they
have too many people they have a lot of
people yeah well maybe we don't need to
worry about China so much since they can
get their army that's what I'm saying
everyone's all like oh my god China's a
thread they're dangerous and I'm like
doing a bunch of losers compared to the
USA you Chuck we have absolutely nothing
to worry about China is just China's
gonna be [ __ ] playing video games and
jacking off I wonder if the guys who
maintain their nukes silos like jerk it
too much
how about that I hope I hope for that
yeah well apparently according to the
same report they're saying that the
United States has 80 percent of
applicants that are
wanna pass due to some other issues 80%
accordingly damn well that's better
there so yeah yeah yeah exactly they're
like are they getting that they can
actually apply that to that study right
I've seen our military and the guys that
apply I'm pretty sure they're not
overweight or scrawny our police force
that's true it's a different question
but our military our ones are in it
that's true they don't have to maintain
their standard of health yeah for police
to you have to have a you have to meet a
physical fitness test requirement but
then after that they don't have to
maintain it so you don't have to like
run a mile a year or some [ __ ]
well there is a I think there is
depending on the department but for most
hmm because I like depending on the
department that tests very to the
physical fitness test it's relatively
similar but some of them seem way harder
like one for LAPD was yet to drag like
this full-body dummy and then you have
to drag it like across this obstacle
course do you throw it I don't think so
you have to pretend like it's a normal
body huh I'm starting to think of a
workaround like I would throw it like
ahead of me and keep picking up on it I
don't know I don't I feel like there was
a time when I did want to join the
military and then I started getting into
like anti-government kind of
conspiracies things and I was like I
don't want them to use me as a as a gun
like they're just using me as a weapon
for their agenda it'll turn to dust your
cowboy dude you gotta watch black mirror
there's an episode where they actually
do that yeah there's a twist and they
want to kill it but it's really because
I I wanted to join so I can shoot guns
because I didn't I couldn't afford like
buying guns so I wanted to shoot guns
and I wanted it like just see how it
felt like to legally kill people whoa
he's like I want to look up the
dictators I wanted to know what it was
like to legally kill somebody I have
friends who were like in family
generational military like his dad's
marine his grandpa's a Marine and all
that right so he recently went to Iraq
and then he was telling me how he was
telling his superior I guess officer
like hey dozes guy that was pretty
injured and he was like on crutches and
he was walking across the street and he
goes he looks like he's gonna die soon
anyway can I shoot it and he's like not
allowed to strike Jordan you're not
allowed to do it
wink basically he's like you're not
allowed to do this but I'm gonna take my
break he said he just shot him
and I was like do that [ __ ] Shady
this guy's the nicest guy in the world
to when he's here it's a different world
Wow he's he's totally he's totally
different like but their gun they're
like trained to use these guys and then
they get like antsy I think you know
yeah but what he did was totally illegal
cuz he just killed an innocent person
but oh my god when I heard that story I
was like man that would have been me if
I joined the military I would have been
desensitized could they turn you into
killers and all they do stupid [ __ ] like
that yeah my brothers are all in the
military my whole family's wonder yeah
they're probably not doing that it's
just if people like maybe turn be like
become one of the military people and
then we start getting curious and we
want to play around if one person
doesn't write the whole you're what's
called a bad egg yeah exactly I would
ruin it I'm gonna run I'll be like a
little situation again if I was allowed
into the military they got low standards
they must be really desperate yeah dude
that's a draft it's like here's your gun
great Wow
hey you want to call me a coward I don't
see you shooting yourself in the foot
well set the ball to shoot myself in the
foot if I do it now though I think I'd
be a medic like if there was a draft and
it's like everyone has to go to or
whatever do something sign up I probably
be a medic I would do I would do the
laundry or I would be a chef
supply guy or whatever they'd be the
accountant for the military why don't I
want to be a medic I want to save life I
was trying to do that and he said it was
the most depressing [ __ ] like you're
just seeing these people that are
[ __ ] bloody and whew that's better
than me shooting people I'm I'm giving
life then then then taking a lot of
people died on you so you're just like
left there with I rather die have people
die on me then be responsible for
killing innocent people
my grandpa was in Vietnam as an airline
mechanic and one of his side jobs was
that he had to go around and collect the
bodies in the morning yeah [ __ ] crazy
Wow so he's like fixing the airplane and
then up and yet the drag bodies out of
the deal yeah cuz they didn't want to
leave behind because my children are
gonna ask me stories about the war and
then they say well what was it like
cause like an automated some bomb-ass
soup and I was also cleaning everybody's
drawers that's providing entertainment
for everyone
that's it I make sure that the linens
were really really white super nice and
they all smelled really good
now I'll heroes where kids some do the
laundry and some people watch gates hey
you guys want to stock any of us we'll
go ahead down to the description box
below and you can follow us on Instagram
and all kinds of stuff for more videos
[Music]